max in his career 10 starts against the
giants 3.86 the era four and five the
overall record well you guys know him
well max has a five-pitch repertoire
goes it all starts with this fastball
fastball command he uses about 47
percent of the time he has a great
change up that he uses only against
lefties and against right-handers he
also throws his slider more often
and this one hit pretty well to left
schwarber circling
here's the first baseman brandon belt
scherzer tried to run the fastball to
the inside edge just a little bit off in
there so far pulling it to his glove
side what's going on
max is trying to stretch some of the
infielders are walking toward the mound
so is davey martinez and here comes paul
lassard oh my so jan gomez will catch a
couple of tosses here
that does not look good something has
happened and max scherzer is leaving
this game
what else can go wrong this year and max
had a little stutter step or a hiccup as
he landed there yeah a little hop at the
end goes for a walk he took a glance
over to the dugout and now he signals to
jan gomes that something is not right
and by that stretch there i think it's
possibly lower back for max to even let
you know davey and the trainer come out
to the mountain you know i didn't feel
something kind of serious paulo espino
has just come out to take over this one
and he will inherit a three and two
count on brandon belt
crawford gets jammed
look at pablo espino taking the bat out
of a couple of the guy's hands so he
gets a couple of quick outs around the
base hit and taking the mound for the
san francisco giants in dc is anthony
disclaifani you look at the numbers
there five and two got that fifth win in
his last start against the cubs 31 year
old right hander really doing a great
job facing those right-handed hitters
that's why you see a few more lefties in
the lineup for the nationals
and that did not last long for bell
strike three three pitches and out on to
the second duggar left-handed hitters
banning 303 in 35 games six doubles and
triple four homers well
steven duggar didn't take the bat off
his shoulder and espino gets him looking
one for 35 on the year against breaking
balls and he gets an 0-2 fastball that
he could not get to up comes the catcher
jan gomes
gomes right center field and the dive
and the catch by lamont way junior well
done it's an incredible play when you
look at it the way he went at it did not
hesitate got a great break on the ball
full extension superman plus he had to
battle the lights you see him closing
his eyes i guarantee that ball got into
the lights and these glopani's excited
and that's a pitcher's best friend one
pitch one out and here's paulo espino
five outs and a base hit on 18 pitches
so far 14 strikes a relief of max
scherzer
right in there and right now pablo
espino is giving some of these hitters
the unexpected
and out to left schwarber measures it
paulo espino
sometimes you do your best work when
you're not expecting to work mercer 236
average 55 at bats no homers no rbis
oh
nasty strike three
second strikeout for d stefani the spino
the pitcher he's only had two at bats
he's over two well he puts espino away
post haste nine in a row retired by d
slavani brandon belt who's batting now
was at the plate when max scherzer had
to leave the game
71 on the curveball follow espino
strikeout number four buster hit a
curveball for a single to left his first
time now here's a curb ball in and
buster hits a high drive deep into the
left center field schwarber all the way
back to the wall he jumps he can't get
it goodbye
that's a home run for buster posey he
just kept throwing him curveballs and
the buster hits this one into the giants
bullpen one nothing giants the 11th home
run of the year for buster posey duggar
left-handed hitting centerfield
who is going to get a high strike call
duggar doesn't like it so with two outs
the giants have two on that brings in
mike talkman that's a swing
good block by gomes inning over john
tagged the batter before and after he
had the baseball big strikeout for
mcgowan ray turner leads off the bottom
of the fourth and trey will calmly take
it to right center he's gonna make a big
round to the bag wade comes up cleanly
with it
and the nets
have their first hit and
base runner juan soto grounded out in
the overshift to solano back in the
first inning and he got him swinging
that is not easy to do he does not do a
whole lot of that soto does not punch
out a whole lot here is josh bowell
bell up the middle crawford there for
one and for two how about that lead off
single with the big hitters coming up
and d slavani pitches right through it
john gomes coming up now
there's a ground ball how about that
let's just get two outs at once giants
turn it two down nobody on starling
castro now
strike three call right on the outside
corner belt posey crawford coming up
shortstop brandon crawford is one for
two
and josh bell right to the back nice
inning for wonder swirl
and here comes robles
now a swing and a high pop-up belt the
first baseman drifting back knight comes
in and toward the foul line and makes
the catch robles retired two down in the
sixth inning and yadiel hernandez will
indeed be the pinch hitter now
he threw it right on the outside got the
foul tip for strike three
six very strong innings ottoman solano
the batter
slow roller caster has one chance bare
hand
and the car was out at first
josh bell stretching and stretching
to stay on that bag and castro ended up
almost down toward the giants on deck
circle after that
great bare handed throw
let's see if josh bill's able to keep
those toes on it hard to tell from that
angle i think he's out there what do you
think
i i think that they have him now it's
juan soto third time around against
anthony d
sitting on the outside
that's right over the heart of the plate
deep left center field
still going back chalkman leaps
and he did it again
he robbed a home run from juan soto he
took it right out of the bullpen
and soto can't believe it just as albert
pujols couldn't believe it a couple of
weeks ago talkman sizes it up times the
leap perfectly
pulls it back
scattering the bullpen menez
so to look into the heavens bottom of
the eighth the nationals trail the
giants one nothing de sclavoni is still
in the game and he chased and he has
done a lot of that for many many years
in the big leagues starling castro
that's the seventh strike out of the
night for december jordy mercer has
struck out and grounded out to second
he's over two and he chased strike three
eight strong and eight strikeouts for d
stefani giants with one lonely run
and so far for eight innings that's been
enough due to the strong efforts of
anthony de slefani who's allowed only
two hits and one walk he's had eight
strikeouts
first ball swinging
and the pinch hitter stevenson pops it
up it is caught right and the top step
of the dugout by bossler man
he didn't have any room for error there
and he was able to catch it without
tumbling down and risking life in limb
chew down but another one of the
nationals top hitters trey turner now
fossler
the second shutout of the year for
diesel funny only the third of his
career
and twice he's done it as a giant